hey everyone i'm madison mills a
reporter here with
bloomberg quick take and today i'm so
excited because i am joined by
sierra and russell wilson and christine
day the former ceo of lululemon
to talk about their new uh fashion brand
house of
lrnc which is a new apparel line that
aims to democratize
fashion thank you all so much for being
here today we're really really
pumped to have this conversation with
you uh sierra and russell i want to
start with
you can you tell me how you came up with
the name behind
house of lrnc and what that means well i
think first of all we were fired up just
to be able to
do this with christine and so when we
were thinking about everything i had
already launched goodman brand and
i can tell you a little bit more about
that in a second but me and c were on a
flight and we were talking about
how each one of these brands we wanted
to have our own identity we
it's kind of like our own babies we got
three kids at home and and uh you know
each of them has their own identity in a
way and so i think a lot of it was
really
making sure that you know what we want
to feel like this is our own house you
know like if you went to your own closet
that's everything you get to get from
but also
uh obviously the lrnc we were thinking
love russell and sierra and they were
like wait hold on a second
what are our true values our true values
were this core concept of love
respect and care and that's what the
house development lrnc
stands for is love respect and care and
so it was a blast you know being able to
do this together with our team and
christine and everybody else and so
it's been cool absolutely it's it's been
really fun and like
i said building that house and the
foundation of those values are really
important to us and
thinking we want to have a little bit
more of a mean more meaning to it it's
not just about fashion it really is
about those values love respect and care
how much better the world will be loved
and respected and cared for each other
more and
um and that's the same passion that we
put into the fashion as well we're
putting a lot of love respect and care
into the detail of everything that we're
doing so
it just felt right to us and it was also
kind of our way of signing off by saying
love russell and sierra
as well so yeah very cool such such a
beautiful message and christine i want
to bring you in here
obviously you have an incredible amount
of experience in the fashion industry
what was different about this process
for you and how did you go about kind of
developing
uh the brand and the style here well so
it's such a great opportunity and i know
that you know the covid kind of pandemic
situation scared a lot of people but
you know we built uh lululemon during
the the the big recession so
it didn't really scare us it just made
us more careful in some of the things
that we did but
i think it's really a time where the
industry is changing
and so to be able to build a new company
from scratch
based on all the values that mean a lot
to me and what i share with russell and
sierra
was really the big opportunity here so
to take advantage of
the sustainability initiatives and build
a brand from scratch
but bring all of those sustainability
initiatives to fashion which
really hasn't been done in the way that
we think it should be
um also taking advantage of some new
technology like flow codes and
and parity and the rival which is about
consumer
um research bringing all of that in to
create what we call
um direct to community so leveraging
tech to create highly
engaged influencers and what we call
activators to create a brand
um so just like there's so much new in
the marketplace right now
from technology to new fabrics
so to have that opportunity to actually
build a company around
all of that with people that i adore
based on really
good impact in everything we do was just
too good to pass up
so i have to ask more about the
technology that you just mentioned what
does that
look like and what did you mean when you
talked about kind of
working with influencers in that space
and using technology to do that more
effectively
well both russell and i know tim
armstrong who started a company called
dtx which is flow codes and unlike
qr codes which kind of are you scan them
and you go to one thing
a flow code you scan it and you go to an
internet
light kind of page of links called a
flow page
so you can create stories and so you
could link to your sustainability
initiatives
we could link to russell and sierra
having messages
our impact the product we can recommend
new products
by putting those flow codes on product
and giving them to influencers
your clothes can talk to you we actually
have right now about
400 what we call activator influencers
who we actually pay between a 20 and 30
commission on
every and the person gets a 10 or 20
discount depending on kind of the season
and item
so it's a really good deal and it takes
it takes advantage of
over 54 of um
gen z would like to be an influencer of
some kind
and so we uh we pay them out after three
months so
um you know they can go big and make it
a career or they can just earn enough
credits to buy
an outfit whatever scale they'd like to
to do and be at it
but it really engages and creates
loyalty with influencers
um and you know just everyday people who
want to be that star
on tick tock right and it kind of
leads me to thinking about this idea of
democratizing fashion that you've talked
about so much i'm curious russell and
sierra if you can talk about
what democratizing fashion means to you
and how you've infused that
into the brand well i think the idea of
democratizing fashion first of all is
that it's
super inclusive and we really wanted to
make sure that
you know it's a participatory you know
brand that you know each
underneath the house of lrc you have
good man brand you have human nation you
have
you know more things coming to come and
and i think that the reality of
uh what christine said human nation
that's that's the influence of brain
everybody's a part of that you know it's
uh everybody who as christine mentioned
tick-tocking and having fun
uh the gen z uh group is is very
important
um i think also too when you think about
good man brand you know i i always say
when i created good man brand the
thought process behind it was
you know i was 25 years old and you know
and the reality was i was dating a girl
way out of my league
and so i wanted to make sure that i
could have you know um i think it's easy
for us to
be able to have that three-point game
meaning that you can dress up in your
suit and tie and
put on a blue blazer and white uh
button-up shirt and a nice blue tie and
everything else and put your dress shoes
on and you also can go
uh you know i call it the layup line
where you can put your shorts and
t-shirt on but that mid-range game is
the key
and uh so that's where we really built
good man brand which has been amazing so
human nation and good man brand
we're all inclusive we really want to be
able to um
really talk to everyone and have
everyone included and as christine
mentioned there's a lot of ways to be
involved and
we're really excited about that and so
we've seen that in our rivals community
we've seen that
in our launch um with uh some amazing
people and being involved in that
process
like jamal and others so uh that's what
democratizing fashion means to us is do
it different
and better for everyone uh better than
any ever before and so hopefully we can
do that
and sierra i'd love to hear from you
about specifically
what your fashion sense has looked like
when you've infused that into the line
and and how you were able to put
parts of yourself and your own
personality and what's important to you
into the clothes i've been having so
much fun you know i think the cool thing
is that so far
even dipping into good van brand there's
everything that i need
you know and i think the ultimate goal
is that when it's all said and done and
the house is fully built out all the
brands that will fall
under the house lrnc that will be a
one-stop shop
and i am a tomboy so i do speak a lot of
that tomboy influence into the
items that we create and design and um
it's been really fun you know fashion is
a big part of my dna
my everyday who i am as entertainer and
i get to express many ways through
fashion
it's been really fun working in this
space and
it's been really it's i'm really like
living out my dream right now which is
pretty awesome so
i'm enjoying every step of the way you
know madison i think the other thing too
is you know when sierra talks about
wearing good man brand she
this this uh this jacket on my back
she's probably gonna wear it later
tonight she
she always my clothes always find her in
my closet medicine but
but um no i think what i want to say
about that though honestly is that
it's been a joy for me you know uh to to
participate in this with sierra and
christine two
brilliant uh minds two amazing women
that influenced so many people have done
so much
and so much good and so for me uh you
know as a male on this and that my
fashion game is good but it's not as
good as theirs
i think for me it's been a blessing to
learn so much and to be
surrounded by such influential women who
have so much thought process and ideas
and
just it's pretty spectacular that our
team is so strong and i'm
i'm grateful for that every day i wake
up that you know yes we get to do this
you know day in and day out but also
you know i get to i get to learn so much
from such amazing women and obviously
sierra being the fashion star that she
is around the world and also christine
being the queen of fashion and brands
and so
it's it's truly this special thing well
i think
sierra is also being modest she
functions as our creative director
so her you know she has actually been
the project
producer behind our videos that we've
done our photography shoots she picks
the models
so she really does function as a
creative director
in our marketing and social media and
digital as well
um and they do a great job um the pair
of them in terms of amplifying our
business so
you know right now flow codes is the
number one uh referral into the site
but russell and sierra drive about 15 of
that traffic so
we get the best of being a celebrity
brand but also
the best of being a technology dtc
experienced kind of entrepreneurial team
that we are in terms of driving the
business
and christine one other thing i heard
you mentioned earlier that i want to dig
into
is the sustainability goals that
hospital rnc has can you talk to me
about
how you've been able to prioritize
sustainability in the creation of the
business
it's been so important and it's been so
much fun so for instance
our tremendous hoodie and jogger set for
human nation
that whole human nation line is over 80
sustainable
we classified every fabric family
into no will never use good better best
so when we say that 80
number it not only meets like the un
standards for sustainability and
transparency
and other like labels like the good
cotton initiative organic cotton etc
but even the way we manufacture
everything
and the fabrics that we use when we say
that 80
it means everything has come from that
good that better or best category that
we do even in um now goodman brand
and importantly in the women's brand
that we'll launch later
we have hit a hurdle of 70 80 which is
unheard of
in fashion you know everybody might have
a small line
or they might have um
you know a few items that actually meet
those hurdles but to design
everything from that ethos also really
taking care that we have green factories
and how the factories are qualified in
terms of how they treat their workers
um you know we go back all the way into
that in how we create every product
and then plus accessible price points
you know i think in human nation
you know our um jogger uh set 78 dollars
compared to something like a pangaea
which is you know about 40 percent more
but similar quality and excitingly has
what we you know we put on technology on
the fabrics
so that has what's called a dwr so it's
a water resistant repellent
um on the the hoodies so when you go
outside it's that perfect
kind of spring jogger set because the
rain just beads right up
and off and so for that kid that you
have that won't wear the coat
we've got covered well christine i'm
glad you bring that up because you know
we are bloomberg so i've got to ask you
a finance question here
the prices are really accessible right
are you all concerned
in any way about being able to make a
profit especially given that you are
giving away a lot of the proceeds
um no we give away the three percent and
that's built into it what you've got in
in this team that russell and i and
sarah have um
assembled are industry experts right we
know
every factory where to buy how we do the
minimum buys how you build your margins
um and you know what we did right from
the start even though we're building a
dtc brand is
we actually picked some strategic
partners like cools and like nordstroms
and what that allows us to do is test
our price points to our minimum buys
right from the beginning we have
strategic partners that are helping us
move through that inventory
hit those minimum buys so we can drive
the margin
and i think that's the difference
between the team that you know we've
assembled and the average
kind of startup um you know entrepreneur
who might have an idea but doesn't know
how to build a business model
and so we know how to build that
business model hit those margins the
minimums
you know that's why things like the
container shortage right now that we
just look at that is another day in the
office you know whereas that might freak
out
you know a smaller startup business
really interesting a lot to learn from
you i'm sure christine
i want to go to russell really quickly
because we mentioned the why not you
foundation
can you talk to me about what that
foundation is and why
it's important to you well you know
that's a great question as you know
my dad used to always ask me you know he
says always say to me son why not you
you know why not you would be in the car
driving from richmond virginia to
virginia beach to see my grandfather and
he'd say to me you know son why not you
why not you do this why not you do that
why don't you play pro baseball pro
football why don't you graduate early in
three years and
why don't you do this and i realized
when he passed away that was
that was the the fundamental question
that we all have to ask ourselves
subconsciously or consciously
at some point in our lives and i think
that that was a big driving force
between
knowing behind the name of the weiner
foundation i was going to name the
russell wilson foundation
i it literally had a whole bunch of
people there to show up in seattle
uh at the time it was called centurylink
field and had a whole bunch of people
there
had these big banners and russell wilson
foundation i said wait hold on a second
this is like two minutes before i went
on stage madison i said
we got to change the name my foundation
director carly looks at me and said what
do you mean you're changing that
we're changing the name we gotta name
the wine on you foundation and
and uh and so it's really not about it's
not not about me it's not about sierra
it's about others
it's really about um inspiring the youth
the next generation and so what's been
amazing about goodman brand ever since
we named
you know named a good man brand the
thought process behind the name of good
man brand first of all
was this idea that you know if we're
gonna name a good man brand well who is
a good man i started thinking to myself
i said my dad was a good man he was the
person who loved he was the person who
served he was person
who gave back he was a person who
respected others and and
he really cared and ultimately though my
dad served he gave back and so when i
thought about that i was like you know
what let's give
let's give at the time it was three
dollars we weren't in canada we weren't
international yet and so
uh three dollars then we realized hey
three percent actually could be even
more
and so we said hey let's give three
percent away and that's been something
a through line behind everything we've
done between me and sierra and
it's been a blessing obviously with the
house of mellor and need to be able to
do that with
human nation good man brand and more to
come and so i think that the goal and
mission
is that you know when much is given much
is required and i think we have a
responsibility especially
in this season of life what where the
pandemics going on so many things
racially going on in the world so many
uh you know there's negative things
going on in the world we want to be a
light in the world and i think that we
can do it through sports and music
but we can also do it through fashion
and when you think about those three
things
it's the three most entertaining things
in the world sports music and fashion
and uh we get to live it every day in
our own house and uh the house of la rnc
i i love and appreciate that so much
thank you so much for sharing that uh
sierra i want to go to you quickly
um i i heard christine mentioned earlier
an upcoming women's brand can you talk
about what that might look like
yes so funny when christina when we get
going we start dropping some
beans um i i definitely can't wait to uh
you know share more with you about
what we've been creating and it's super
exciting um again we want to be that
one-stop shop for women and that's all i
can tell you right now
interview madison we'll talk about it
but it's super exciting
really exciting what we've been creating
and what we're doing thus far and um
just really proud of where we are to
this point right fair enough fair enough
and one thing on the topic of gender
that i found really
cool uh is that the hoodies on the site
switch genders based on the different
colors you pick um there's not like a
women's only hoodie and a men's only
hoodie
and also the sizing system was so cool
i'd definitely rather pick
number four than a large for my hoodie
for example
sierra how did you go about developing
that side of things and was that
you know a really intentional part of
your thinking behind developing the
clothes
absolutely i love hearing you say how
you like picking the number four versus
the letter
um you know we are gender neutrals being
a gender-neutral brand and
how it's really important to us um and
so we definitely want to make sure we're
factoring in like the inclusivity part
was very important
and it is really for everyone you know
everyone should be able to see
themselves in the line they should be
able to see themselves in the clothing
and
you know it isn't about putting a
particular face or shape or size
you know on someone's identity or
through fashion like fashion is about
you expressing yourself in the truest
form of who you are
and that's what we welcome we welcome
everyone to come to the house
be you be who you are we celebrate who
you are individually
and collectively and so um we definitely
made a conscious effort about that and
it was really fun educating ourselves in
the process with with christine and
therese and the whole team that really
knows you know how to do this
and um it just was really fun seeing it
all develop and to see how when you say
that madison that makes me really proud
because it says mission is accomplished
right
it's a good feeling to hear that right
well christine i'm curious
what what kind of trends within the
fashion industry you think
are mirrored by that is this something
that you think that we're moving towards
collectively is this kind of
non-sizing environment yeah
i mean definitely we see the white space
as gender neutral
all inclusive and being able to express
what was interesting
um we have about a 400 group in our what
we call rival community where we test
and ask questions and fans that are all
like gen z
so we did actually ask a lot about this
and what surprised us when it came back
was that pink was the top selling
um you know color recommendation from
them even before we started sales
both men and women so you know i don't
think people realize
actually um you know that pink is
considered a neutral for men and women
now
so you know this gives people that
ability clothing is
along i think with music and art are you
know
are the biggest modes of self-expression
and dance i would add to that as well
so you know we that's what we see
happening
is more and more personal style um being
reflected in how young people in
particular are dressing
and you know less following of mega
trends and more kind of personal
and um and then you know embracing that
kind of unity
and of diversity and i know that kind of
sounds a little bit like an oxymoron but
um you know people like to see diversity
and they feel unified
um by acceptance of others and that's
really a trend that we think will be
continuing
in fashion right right and in our final
minute here
russell and sierra i know that christine
just mentioned the importance of
diversity and that is such a through
line in the products
what was your thinking behind developing
the specific
wording that you would put on the shirts
that you have and how did you come up
with
uh the message that you really wanted
people to take away from the clothes
well i think that's a great question i
think the time is now you know
um you know we have a shirt a t-shirt
for for example with human nation
if not now when you know i think that um
you know the reality of we have a
responsibility me and sierra
um to really give back and to make a
difference and to really take a stand
on on change and i think that christine
is right there with us our whole team
house of lrc um and and it's it's been a
blessing
when you think about you know the names
even of our individual brands good man
brand we think about human nation
it's about it's about everyone else it's
about really making a difference and
really inspiring good we want to be
known as as good brands you know and not
just
quality but also you know the ability to
really
you know from the community standpoint
of it all and uh there's so much going
on in the world and i think
you know our identity of you know our
values that you know of the house of lrc
love respect and care
it's what the world needs right now and
like i said earlier sports and music
fashion the most entertaining things in
the world and i i'm glad i get to do it
next to her and
she she makes the day better every day
so oh
that's true yeah we're living in a very
expressive time right and people really
are expressing themselves and we
celebrate that
at the house of lrnc and through our gen
z ran human nation and beyond and so
we just want to be able to you know
obviously be a great platform for all
your fashion needs
but also be a place where there's a
community and people when they feel like
they join the nation or you become a
part of what we're doing under the house
of lrnc that you're part of doing
something that's really
making a difference that's also moving
something right you know we can just
take one little bitty steps to make
great steps you know we're doing
something together
so you know that's um that's what we're
about and um it's just really cool being
able to express your fashion so
yes a lot of statement teas and and more
like you said inclusivity
for everyone um every gender every
welcome everyone at the house
of lrnc well i think that is a wonderful
place to leave it house of lrnc
co-founders christine day
sierra and russell wilson really
appreciate all of you for joining us and
thank you to our quick take audience for
watching you can follow us on all social
platforms facebook instagram twitter
youtube and watch our streaming show
as well for now i'm madison mills in new
york thank you all so much
thank you so much